we have some really great political
discussions happening on the david
pakman show subreddit which you can find
at david pakman.com slash our IDI di t a
couple of interesting posts i want to
point out and talk about one is called
CR TV ads and this viewer points out
that they want to know why they keep
seeing ads for CR TV on our videos on
youtube they are asking is there a
particular reason for this or is it the
YouTube algorithm not liberal or
conservative but I wanted to see but if
I wanted to see conservative propaganda
or liberal propaganda I'd prefer not
having to see hundreds of the exact same
ad from the opposing side so if you
don't watch the show on YouTube you
might not know that CR TV is a
right-wing I guess we would call it a
right-wing TV channel YouTube presence
and an online presence and they have
been running ads all over news and
politics on YouTube regardless of
ideology we don't control the specific
ads that show up on our channel but it
is interesting that they are running so
many ads that end up on left-wing
YouTube channels and they've actually
been caught with fake staged interviews
like they did an interview that looked
like an interview with Alexandria Cascio
cortes but it wasn't it was her video of
her spliced with some CR TV host or
something like that really deceptive
stuff and unfortunately their tactics
are working and they are building an
audience but yeah we that they're all
over our YouTube channel we have no
control over over them advertising with
us but a lot of people have pointed it
out to me also from the david pakman
show subreddit way in warren 2020
talking about elizabeth warren for
president in 2020 she got my attention
when she presented that corruption bill
says Siddim now elizabeth warren is
openly considering launching her
campaign immediately following the
midterms what do you think could she
bridge the divide between progressives
and right-leaning democrats there really
aren't as many rightly leaning democrats
as maybe some would like to believe
Elizabeth Warren did say to a standing
ovation at a
in Holyoke Massachusetts I believe it
was a few days ago that she is after the
midterms going to seriously consider
whether she wants to run for president
I have sort of made it a policy that I'm
not ready I don't think we should be
talking about 2020 until we get past the
midterms but I am going to have a lot to
say about the potential of an Elizabeth
Warren candidacy it's only another four
weeks and then we're gonna start talking
about it
lastly from the David Pakman show
subreddit Neal Gorsuch wasn't accused of
sexual assault this is an important
thing people have pointed out that the
idea that the Cavanaugh sexual assault
allegations are part of a smear campaign
or or fake and trumped up really doesn't
make sense because if this was the
strategy with Trump Supreme Court picks
why didn't they do it - Neal Gorsuch and
the answer is quite simple there are
genuine sexual assault allegations
against Brett Kavanaugh there were not
against Neal Gorsuch that's the reason
that you don't have to look too deeply
or start to think about are these fake
are those fake is as Brett Kavanaugh
suggested are the Clintons may be
involved in the sexual assault
allegations against Brett Kavanaugh the
explanation is very simple there weren't
people who felt that Brett Neal Gorsuch
had sexually assaulted them so nobody
came forward there are multiple women
who claimed to have been sexually
assaulted by Brett Kavanaugh and that's
why we're hearing from them sometimes
the truth is really very simple join the
discussion on the david pakman show
subreddit david pakman.com slash re d di
t